you've talked about it which is really
interesting framing
is uh escaping bad positions
is one of the best ways if not the best
way
to demonstrate dominance
psychologically over your opponent that
anything they throw at you
like their weapons are useless against
you um
there's a little bit of legs friedman
kicking through on this question
your obsession with dominance is um uh
it's your therapy session it's the
therapy session
i'm coming from a wrestling perspective
i think it's not just lex friedman i
think it's dan gable i think it's
dominant the gary tonan ethic
it just goes against everything
wrestling is about you
never put yourself in a bad position and
the fact this it's a philosophical i
don't know what to do with it it's a
total reframing
of showing dominance
by escaping any bad position
yeah let's talk about the idea of what
what what is the value of escapes
why do i put this in as as the first
skill
that every jiu jitsu student must master
believe it or not when i talked about
how it
pertains to dominance that's its
smallest value
its greatest value has nothing to do
with dominance it has to do with
confidence
you can train someone and teach them
technique
until you're blue in the face but at
some point
the athlete in question has to go out
there on the stage
and pull the trigger when the time is
right
what's going to give you that ability to
go from the physical
skills that you've learned to execution
under pressure is confidence
i always talk about skill development
and yes
skill development is the absolute
bedrock of my training programs
but you can't finish at that level
there has to be something more than that
and you have to go
from the physical element of skill into
the psychological element of confidence
i can teach you an armbar all day
you can get to a point where you can
flawlessly execute armbars
and drilling and even in a certain level
of competition
but if you believe that in attempting an
armbar on a dangerous opponent with good
guard passing skills
say the albar has been performed from
guard position
that if the armbar fails and your
opponent
uses that failure to set up a strong
pass
and get into a side pin possibly into
the mount
and you don't have the ability to get
out of that side panel mount
you won't pull the trigger on the armbar
and so even though you had
all the requisite physical skills to
perform the technique
when push came to shove and the critical
moment came
you back down you didn't pull the
trigger
building that confidence is the key
to championship performance and the
single
best way to do it is to take away the
innate
fear that we all have of bad
outcomes that makes us naturally risk
averse
when you don't believe you can be pinned
when you don't believe your guard can be
passed
you'll take risks because there's no
downside to your actions
an unpinnable person and an unpossible
person
doesn't have much to fear in a jiu jitsu
match you can come out and fire with all
guns blazing
because then you know at the end of the
day no one's going to hold you down no
one's going to pass your guard
that's your first two goals in jiu-jitsu
they're the most boring goals
they're not exciting to learn no one
wants to come in the first minute told
okay you're going to practice escapes
for the next year of your life okay so
i'm going you're kidding me
but that's what you gotta have that's
your first skill
and that's what i push upon all of my
students you'll see
almost all of them are very very strong
and escape skills
they know that if things go wrong they
can always get out
they can always live to fight another
day
and that is what gives them the ability
to attack without fear
i think that is so profound and so rare
it's so rare to hear this i think it's
because it's the most painful thing to
do
always ask yourself when you enter a
youtube match
you already know ahead of time
if you're going to lose how you're going
to lose
okay there's only a certain number of
realistic submissions that work in the
sport of judas who the number is very
small
so ahead of time you already know
the most likely methods of submission
loss and jujitsu are going to be things
like heel hook
renegade strength or guillotine et
cetera et cetera just work backwards
from that knowledge
so start off learning how to defend all
of those things
you know what the major losing positions
are in jiu-jitsu someone gets mounted on
you rear mount
side control neon valley those positions
you can only lose from
so work backwards from there getting out
of those positions
and that's how i always start i always
say with my students
i teach beginners from the ground up
and i teach experts backwards
what does that mean when a young student
comes to me with no skills
they learn from the ground up they start
on their backs defending pins
then they start on their backs working
from half guard bottom
then on their backs working from
variations of guard they don't even get
to see top position
until they're strong off their backs
then
they go onto their knees and they start
passing
start standing and passing and then they
work their pins and transitions
and then ultimately they stand up to
their feet and they work
standing position on their feet so they
work from ground
back on the floor to ground knees on the
floor
ground standing and then both athletes
standing is a gradual progression over
time where they work from the bottom to
the top
with regards experts i teach them
in-game
first they must become very very strong
in what finishes the match which is
submission holds
you